[Applaudissements]
juste après dany brillant et sinclair
danny messer ils étaient près ils
étaient ils étaient là mais j'étais là
il était chaud alors venez vous mettre
la venelle a fini arrêtez-vous là avec
les lieux les lieux que vous avez des
voix de crooner vous faites les
bombasses attention c'est parti de là et
nous chanter your world award for me for
me formidable mais on prend le dessus
attention prenez tout de suite
[Musique]
bondissant bien
you are domaine termine formi formi
formidable very very privé
mais je voudrais
là je
enfin que dire
[Musique]
dans la langue de
2 c'est cuit shoprite taille désaisie
désir d idéal
je suis malheureux
car si peu
moha d'offrir aux cadeaux là
boulogne est un
oui c'est à peu près tout you are the
one free paris orly florida
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez